I think it's become far too easy to do
the jump scares these days I like to
kind of build it almost like something
musical you take the audience to the
edge of the cliff think it's about to go
off and then you don't I think it's
really that ride to that point this
getting to sex metal quarry know
the anatomy of a good scare well I will
use an example from insidious Alaska so
first you have to start with a context
where you pre-charge the the audience
right and so the prologue
young Elise in her bed and it's dark and
you get the movie nice and quiet she's
having a conversation
[Music]
then you quickly realize that
brother who's above her is not her
brother because as she opens the
partition and we show the audience the
mr. Agra sees her brother's actually
sitting on this chair so suddenly you
just when you think you're gonna get a
jump you realize as she's padding down
the bed that there's nothing there
you let the audience breathe just a
little bit more of a beat then you do
the sting
[Music]